The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What I want to do now
is basically summarize the
theme of each of the sessions
that we've had, partly as a
way of reminding you of all
the things we did and also
jogging your memory or any
question that you might have
about that.
And then it'll be your chance
to ask questions.
So I'm going to do it, so
I'll think aloud here.
I'll do it in a way that I can
leave them up the whole time.
So let me do it here.
I'll do it on these two guys.
Yeah, I'll do it here.
So our sessions and the
summaries of them--
so session number one was
the introduction.
But I'll start with session two,
was teaching equations.
Now the fundamental idea I
wanted people to learn in this
one is to help students learn
equations in big chunks.
So doing derivations
is generally
antithetical to that.
Because students will just see
the little symbols, and
they'll see a ton and ton and
ton and ton of symbols.
And they're chunk size is much
smaller than you, so you will
overload their short
term memory.
And they won't really be
understanding, they'll be just
trying to remember and write
as fast as they can.
So is that visible,
the orange?
Yeah?
Great.
Oh yeah, you're a good test.
So teaching equations, you
want to try and chunk the
equations, because that gives
meaning for the students.
So, for example, what
does each term mean?
Why would you expect that term
to show up in the equation?
Those are the kinds of things
that a book generally does not
do very well.
And that's something that you,
as a teacher, actually have a
lot of value to add.
Now I just learned about a book
that does try to do this,
which is called A Student's
Guide to Maxwell's Equations.
Does anybody know that book?
Yeah, you know it?
So, it looks fantastic.
I'm number seven or something
in the queue to get a copy
from the MIT library, which
shows how popular it is.
But the way it's organized--
well, first of all, it's sold
an immense number of copies
for a technical textbook,
something like 7,000 or
something like that.
So it's a physics best seller.
It's not an Agatha Christie
novel, but
it's really well done.
And each chapter talks about
one of the equations.
So there's four, roughly,
Maxwell's equations.
And there's four chapters,
one per equation.
So it's helping the students
chunk just by the very
structure of the books.
But most books don't do that,
aren't that well or that
interestingly constructed, and
that thoughtfully constructed,
so it's something that you, as
a teacher, really should do.
The next one--
misconceptions.
So why did we spend a whole
session on misconceptions?
Well, it's fundamentally
important, misconceptions,
because if you don't know where
your students are, you
have no chance of bringing
them to where you
want them to go.
The example that's classic,
that's [? probably ?]
started this whole line of
research about misconceptions,
was students' understanding
of force and motion.
And basically, what you find
is that most peoples'
intuitive understanding
of force and
motion is f equals mv.
If you have an object,
you stop pushing
it, it stops moving.
Force and velocity
are connected.
If you have a heavier object,
you have to push it harder.
If you have a lighter object,
you push it less.
So force and mass are connected,
so it looks
like f equals mv.
Whereas, we would like to
teach them f equals ma,
Newton's Second Law, force
equals mass times
acceleration.
So there's a fundamental
difference there, and if you
don't take account of that,
you'll end up producing just
rote knowledge.
They'll say OK, well whenever
I happen to be in physics
class, I'll use f equals ma, and
I'll just solve problems
symbolically using that
procedure you've told me.
But I don't really believe it,
or understand it, or use it in
my own reasoning, so my
intuition is no longer
available for reasoning.
So by taking account of
students' misconceptions and
helping them come to an
intuitive understanding of how
things really work,
you're actually
making them much smarter.
So this is knowing--
so that's knowing how
students think.
So this is pretty much opposite
to behaviorism.
Because you're saying, well, I
really want to peer into how
people are reflecting, and how
their cognition works, what's
going on under the hood.
And behaviorism says, well, no,
all you need to do is look
at the behavior.
If they're solving problems
correctly, that's fine.
Whereas actually you want to
know, well, why did they solve
it that way?
Is it because they really
understood it or not?
Did they just say 6 times 3 is
18, because they were told, or
they memorized it?
Or was it because they really
understood it, in which case
they could make a word problem
related to it?
So knowing how students think,
you're actually part of the
cognitive revolution.
And you're actually connecting
to students, directly and
making them much smarter.
Homework and exam questions--
so constructing homework and
exam questions, the main theme
of that was Bloom's Taxonomy.
So this was a hierarchy of goals
that you could have.
So the full name is A Taxonomy
of Educational Objectives.
And the ones we're talking
about, if you look at the full
title, it's the cognitive
domain.
There's the cognitive
and affective.
Affective means related to
feelings and emotions.
This is the cognitive domain
ones I'm talking about here.
So are you asking for
just comprehension?
Are you asking for students
to analyze?
Are you asking them to
synthesize knowledge?
What is the level of cognitive
activity that
you're asking for?
And generally, you want
to mix levels.
So you don't want to just
push the students
off a cliff and say--
the first day in thermodynamics
class, discuss
how the Second Law of
Thermodynamics applies to the
entropy of the universe?
That's just too hard.
You've pushed them way off the
cliff, and you jumped way too
high in Bloom's Taxonomy.
You also don't want to just give
them pure comprehension
problems, because they remember
the rule that you're
trying to teach.
Rather, you want to mix them,
and Bloom's Taxonomy gives you
a structured way of seeing what
level your questions are
at and making sure you mix
them, so that you prepare
students comprehension
questions, so that they can
later do evaluation questions.
Course design--
so for course design, the
big idea is big ideas.
So you want to organize your
course around some kind of
large ideas.
And ideally, those large ideas
will transfer outside of the
course too.
And if a whole curriculum is
organized around a few large
ideas, for example, waves and
oscillatory motion, you could
also organize a whole bunch of
a physics major around ideas
like that, or conservation.
By giving structure to the
curriculum, you turn it away
from just a series of
unconnected facts, like we did
this topic, that topic, that
topic, that topic, actually
you give it form and
organization.
And then it's much more likely
to be built into long lasting
chunks in the students' minds.
So the next one was interactive
teaching.
The sixth session was
interactive teaching.
And the main theme is that
questioning and reflecting
lead to long lasting learning.
So I showed you three or four
different time scales on which
you could be interactive.
A short one is when you ask a
question, you wait 5 seconds.
Or actually some of you
suggested seven, which is
probably better.
It's just harder to do, but
it's probably better.
So you wait a certain amount
of time to allow people to
actually formulate questions.
So that promotes interaction
on a short scale.
You can ask short questions,
one or two minutes, two or
three minutes, with a multiple
choice right in
the middle of lecture.
It gives you feedback.
So it's related to the
misconceptions one.
You're learning how students
think, just as
they answer the questions.
Or on the same time scale, you
can ask the feedback questions
from this sheet at the
end of the lecture.
So that's also promoting
a space for questions.
And you can actually see
how successful that is.
There's so many questions,
actually, we could spend two
more sessions answered
all the questions,
which I'm glad about.
Because questioning
and reflecting--
that's how people make
knowledge their own.
So the formal name for that
is constructivism.
But what you're doing is
you're helping people
construct knowledge.
And you can do this
on a long scale.
Like for example, for the whole
lecture, you can use a
question like the word blocks,
which I showed you earlier.
You can actually do that
for an entire lecture.
And actually, we just did that
for entire lecture in my Art
of Approximation class.
Because the word blocks leads
to xylophones, and I brought
in a xylophone.
And we can talk about how the
pitches of the thick and thin
wood blocks relate to the
pitches of shorter and longer
xylophone slats.
So rich examples like that--
one doesn't have that
many of them.
But when you do have them, you
can actually build an entire
session around them.
And it produces all of
these good things.
Seven--
lecture planning
and performing.
So for the planning of the
lecture, just like for the
course, the planning of a
course, you want to organize
it around some kind of big idea,
some kind of thing that
gives it structure.
The whole lecture, you
want an objective.
For example, by the end of the
lecture, I want students to be
able to explain the origin
of the terms in the
Navier-Stokes equation.
So then you would choose
your activities in
lecture around this goal.
But that goal, actually just
like the longer scale one for
the whole course, gives
structure to the lecture.
And you know what to put in
and what not to put it.
And the lecture planning blank
sheets, or the templates I
gave you, I posted, you can
use those to that end.
And that's for the
planning part.
And for the performing, I would
say the main thing in
performing that people don't
normally think about when they
think about teaching
is timing.
So if you want to create little
bits of suspense and
interest, little bits
of tension,
that are then released.
And you want to do that
on multiple scales--
short and long.
The interactive teaching
questions from here help do
that, especially if you
have a demonstration.
Because people want to know, is
the thick wood block going
to be higher pitch or is it
going to be a lower pitch?
And you'll find that when you
do things like that, the
entire room is dead silent,
because people
really want to know.
And the way you structure the
questions can promote that.
By having people vote, they've
now made a public commitment,
which then activates the
cognitive dissonance part of
people's mind.
By making a public commitment,
they've now made their
internal state more towards the
public state, which is oh,
I want to know what's
going on.
And they really do want to
know what's going on.
So timing-- you can get a lot
of timing ideas from the
interactive teaching methods.
But timing is really important
for performing.
Imagine jokes where people tell
you the punchline first,
and then they tell you
the rest of the joke.
They don't go over too well, and
most comics, at least most
successful comics,
don't do that.
But we usually do that
with our teaching.
Blackboards and slides
for teaching--
so the main concepts to think
about there are the chunk size
that students have and how many
spots they have in short
term memory.
So with the blackboard, you have
many advantages for free,
which is that on the blackboard,
you don't have to
use too many short term
memory slots.
You can put the entire session
all on one giant set of
blackboards in the front.
And you can offload a lot of the
work onto something that's
in the visual field
and present for
everyone, all the time.
Because remember, their
chunk size is much
smaller than yours.
So you might see the entire
lecture as one chunk.
But obviously, they don't see it
that way, or they wouldn't
be in the lecture.
They're the learners.
And then when you're doing the
slides, if you're going to use
slides for teaching, to mitigate
some of this problem
of not having enough short term
memory slots, generally
not enough space, well, you
could try to get four slide
projectors or three
slide projectors.
But it's pretty hard to do.
And it triples or quintuple
or [? nontuples ?]
the time to prepare the slides,
because you have to
synchronize three different
slide presentations.
So at least use assertions
at the title
and then visual evidence.
Visual evidence is much
easier to remember.
And the assertions help people
know what to look for.
So they're not spending all
their cycles, which they don't
have that many of, because
their short term
memory's been filled up.
They're spending their cycles
trying to understand the
visual evidence.
And I posted a set of example
slides with the [? text ?]
source.
There was a request
for the [? text ?]
source, so I posted that, as
well, showing this method of
presentation for the factorial,
the logarithm of
the factorial.
And then the last one
was [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe the summary
could be--
the comment that was on
one of the sheets was
is there any hope?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And I think,
well, that question--
it's coupled to another
question.
So the main theme from that is
that social and educational
change are coupled.
So if there's no hope
for education,
there's no hope for society.
Or alternatively, if there's
hope for society, there's hope
for education, and vice versa.
So the main positive lesson from
this is that by improving
society, you improve education,
and also, by
improving education, you
improve society.
So that's one really good reason
to want to be a teacher
and to make teaching a part of
your career, as I'm sure many
of you are thinking
about doing.
So those are the short
summaries of the nine sessions.
And what I'd like to do now is
give you a chance to ask any
questions you have.
We'll, of course, have our--
let's see, in 10 minutes, at
10 o'clock, we'll take a 10
minute break.
But before that, I want to start
the question session.
So the way we'll do that is if
everyone could just look at
your index card that you brought
with a question, or it
doesn't have to be an index
card, it could be a sheet of
paper, and spend one minute
thinking about something that
puzzles you, you wonder about,
you're interested in, you'd
like to know more about, about
anything related to teaching,
and check in with a
neighbor or two.
And then we'll just start
doing questions.
And then we'll have our
break at 10:00.
I'll leave all these
guys up here, and
I'll mark your questions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Take another 10 or
20 seconds to formulate a
question or formulate your
thoughts, and we'll start.
AUDIENCE: So--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Implicitly throughout
this semester,
we've been thinking that our
audiences, like the college
age audience--
so if you're teaching older
people, [INAUDIBLE]
things that you have
to do differently?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
So let me repeat the question,
and then also, that will give
me a chance to bring in one of
the other comments from the
question sheets.
So the question was what about
teaching older learners, so
people who aren't college age,
so middle aged people?
Do you have to do things
differently?
And now, before I answer
that, let me say why
I repeat the question.
So their comment was that it's
a good idea to repeat the
question, because OCW asks that
I repeat the question.
Because the pick up, the
microphone pick up, I guess,
is here, and it picks up me much
better than the audience.
So it's good for that, but
it's also good, as the
commenter pointed out.
It's good, because it shows the
students who are asking
the question that I actually
value their questions.
Because I'm actually telling
everybody, look, this is
something we should all
be thinking about.
So it brings the whole class
together around it, and it
also gives me time to think
about the question.
Although, in this case, I didn't
actually use any of
that time to think about the
question, so let me think
about the question now.
So I'm not sure it actually
gives you that much time.
It gives you one
or two seconds.
But actually, if you want one
or two seconds, it's best to
just sit there still and think
for one or two seconds.
So that's what I'm
going to do now.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So now I waited
actually four seconds just to
show that it's possible to do
that, though difficult.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So there are some
things that are different.
And I would say one of the main
differences is not just
the misconceptions, but the
conceptions of learning that
people have.
So for example, you might be
teaching people who just
failed out of math in school and
never did math again, and
now you want to help
them learn math.
Or you want to help them learn
reading, and they always
thought of themselves
as terrible readers.
So now they've imbibed the
lesson of the blue eyes brown
eyes experiment, which is that
they're bad at this-- for
whatever reason, it's
their fault.
And we're very good at that.
We're very good at
passing blame.
So why didn't people
learn physics?
Well, physics is a very
hard subject.
It's not that we teach
it terribly,
it's a very hard subject.
So basically, we're saying,
blame the victim.
I know that's very convenient.
But after a while of that, the
victim actually starts to get
Stockholm Syndrome.
So they start to identify
with their captors.
And they agree, yes, physics
is a really hard subject.
I never had a head
for physics.
So as an experiment for that,
next time you go to a party,
ask people what you do--
I mean, obviously not a party of
other graduate students in
science and engineering,
because that test
wouldn't work here.
But just for example, my office
mate, when I was a
graduate student, he used
to live in Hollywood, in
Hollywood, itself.
So he used to go to parties,
and his roommate
was a script rewriter.
So his roommate would
actually--
scripts that were considered
too bad even to make movies
out of, but they really thought
they should make a
movie out of it, because they
thought they could make a lot
of money if they just rewrote
the script a bit, so like
D-grade scripts that needed to
be made C-grade, his roommate
rewrote them.
So he had a lot of Hollywood
connections.
So he had a lot of parties with
people who weren't from
Caltech, which was good.
So go to a party like that,
and when people say,
oh what do you do?
Say, oh I'm a chemistry graduate
[? student, ?]
I teach physics, or I'm a TA for
this class, or I'm working
on a Ph.D. in mathematics.
And just watch how
fast people run.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So if they're not
very polite, they'll say oh,
what do you do?
Right?
But if they're more polite,
they'll actually say, oh,
yeah, I always was terrible
with that.
That was never my thing.
And this is so prevalent.
So now, what do you have
to do in that case?
So that's their misconception.
And so number three up there,
you have to really take
account of that.
Their way of thinking about math
and physics, the way that
it was taught to them completely
did not work, and
it just produced fear
and phobia.
So now what you have to do is
you have to go around that.
And so one of the ways actually
Brian Butterworth,
who actually studies this--
he's a professor of
neurophysiology, in London.
And I mentioned his book a
couple times, I think, it's
called The Mathematical Brain
or What Counts, depending on
whether it's the English
or American title.
So math phobia a lot caused by
people having a fear that
there's only one way to
get the right answer.
So they think they're walking
across a tight rope, and if
you make it one misstep, then
you fall into the abyss.
And so, of course, if you
have that conception of
mathematical reasoning and
problem solving, you're going
to have a lot of fear.
So what you have to
do is you have to
show people, no, actually--
right over here.
So if this was their model, that
if that's the one way to
get to the solution, actually
you want to show them not
that, and show them
even dead ends.
Not every method of solution
will work out.
Some might just end up there,
and some might end up there.
And some connect to other
methods and get to a solution.
And even maybe, that's
one solution, but
maybe there's two.
So you want to show them that
there's robust paths across
the river, let's say.
You're not trying to, for
example, jump Niagara Falls,
where one misstep
and down you go.
So that's a way of reducing
the math phobia.
Now that's a particular example,
but that's an example
of how you have to think
slightly differently for the
adult learner.
The reason is that they've had
longer time to internalize the
misconception.
The high school student, for
example, they haven't
necessarily formed their
own view of them self.
And it's less true at the
college level, that people are
starting to form their view of
self more and more, but it's
still changeable, especially
in America.
And that's one really excellent
part of the American
university system.
So you may not realize it if you
come from America, but in
almost every other country in
the world, when you go to
university, you pick your
subject and that's what you do
for the rest of the
university time.
So England, for example,
it's even before that.
If you want to do physics at
Cambridge, you have to have
done, for the last two years
of high school--
basically everyone who did
physics at Cambridge did
physics, math, chemistry, and
further maths, I should say.
So further maths are
just more maths--
basically like DE calculus.
so they did, for the last two
years of school, only math and
physics and chemistry courses.
And then they go on
to university, and
they do just physics.
And Cambridge had a radical
innovation on that, which was
that in the first year, you
didn't do just physics, you
did physics, math, chemistry,
and maybe a fourth subject.
So that was considered really
very progressive.
And it was compared
to the rest of
the educational system.
So in Europe, in general, there
isn't that freedom.
So in America, you
still have it.
So the students in college are
still going to be quite
different from the people who've
basically fixed their
view of them self as bad at
math or bad at whatever.
And that's one of the things
that you change when you're
thinking about adult learners.
I'll take one question
back there, and then
we'll have our break.
AUDIENCE: So towards the
beginning of the class, we
talked about the experiment in
math teaching in New Hampshire
PROFESSOR: Benezet,
the experiment?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the Benezet
experiment.
I don't think we ever really
got to figuring out what
happened to that.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So what happened
to the Benezet
experiment in New Hampshire?
So Louis Benezet was
superintendent of schools in
Manchester, New Hampshire
from 1924 to 1938.
And so what happened?
If it was so great,
where is it now?
So I might have mentioned that
I actually went and did
research on what
happened to it.
And I went to the Manchester,
New Hampshire school board and
just spent a whole day in their
archives reading all the
minutes of all the school board
discussions about it and
all the votes about Benezet and
whether to reappoint him
as superintendent or what to
do about the curriculum.
And basically, what happened
was two things.
So first of all, there was
extensive studies done showing
that the curriculum was
very successful.
So one study was by--
so Etta Berman, she
was a teacher in
Manchester in the program.
And then she did her master's
in education I'm pretty sure
at Boston University.
Yes, I'm sure it is, because you
can find her thesis in the
Boston University library.
So her education thesis was an
assessment of how the students
did in that experimental
program
versus the regular program.
And the students in the
experimental program were just
much better.
It was just totally clear.
So now what happened?
Well, what happened, partly,
I think a lot of it is what
Alfie Kohn article about "Not
for my Kid: How Privileged
Parents Undermine School
Reform." So there was huge
opposition from the privileged
parents.
And so I interviewed some of
the people who had those
privileged parents and who
had taken that curriculum
50 or 60 years ago.
And one of them was later mayor
of Manchester, and he
said his parents just hated
the curriculum.
So generally, the people whose
parents were foreign, for
example, French Quebecois who
had come to New Hampshire, had
to work in the mills, the
non-English speakers, the
lower middle class, it was
OK, and it was fine.
And the ones I talked to from
that background loved the
curriculum.
And then the few who really
hated it were actually
socially quite powerful,
and they came from the
predominately English
speaking families.
And they hated that he wasn't,
for example, giving homework.
Because he said, if you have
eight hours of school, what
more homework do you
need, which I
think is actually true.
If you can't teach people in
eight hours a day, that's
ridiculous.
That's 40 hours a week.
So why are you giving them
still more homework?
So he didn't have homework, he
had them actually learn in
school, which is one
of the benefits
of interactive teaching.
If your lecture is no longer
dictation, you are actually
learning, you don't have to do
a lot of stuff out of school.
So there was opposition,
there.
And what happened was the votes
in the school board went
something like this.
So this is t.
So this is 1938 and 1924.
And this is the votes in
favor, minus against.
They went roughly like this.
So the school board, I think
it had 15 people
on it, or 14 people.
It depended, sometimes
one person wasn't
on the school board.
So the first votes were
something like 13 to 1, so in
other words, plus 12.
And then, over here, 1924, when
he was first appointed,
and then the votes went like
this, and then it started
going down like that.
And by 1938--
so there was votes taken every
three or four years, or two
years, whether to renew the
appointment, because
that was the term.
And by here, the vote was
6 to 6 right here.
Yeah, that's right-- it
was 6 to 6 in 1937.
And then what happened in 1938
was they didn't vote to not
take him on, but what they did
is they voted to use a
standard textbook.
So they voted to use a standard
textbook in the
curriculum, and then the
curriculum was then declared
incompatible with the
standard textbook.
Of course, the standard textbook
was pretty terrible.
Well, I don't know the
textbook, personally.
But I'm sure, given the
state of standard
textbooks, then and now.
And it certainly wasn't the
progressive, understand the
algorithms approach
that Benezet had.
So then the textbook was
instituted, and the curriculum
was basically killed
off, like that.
So then Benezet left for
a professorship of
education at Dartmouth.
And then, after Benezet left--
so this is Benezet--
Benezet left, the new
superintendent put in a,
basically, drill and kill
curriculum with lots of
testing and the standard now.
There was No Child Left Behind
60 years before or 70 years
before its time.
But the curriculum was very
successful, and it was
basically killed off by
opposition from wealthy
parents and, to be fair, Benezet
didn't help his case.
So a couple of the students told
me that actually when the
students wouldn't answer things
in class, he would
sometimes make fun of them.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Now that's
terrible.
I mean it's terrible just on
moral grounds, but also it's
terrible political strategy.
Because now, the kids will tell
their parents, and if the
parents needed ammunition, at
all, there they have it.
And so Benezet was just
arming the enemy too.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If, presumably, most
or all of us would be teaching
college level courses,
we don't have
to worry about parents.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Is it a comparable
force to the parents
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, there is.
Good question.
So is there a comparable force
in college education to
parents with privilege?
Yeah, and unfortunately
it's one's
colleagues on the faculty.
The reason is because they were
the ones who did well by
the old system.
And so now a change is likely to
be misinterpreted or maybe
rightly interpreted as well,
this isn't for the benefit of
the top 5%.
So we can't do it.
So for example, interactive
teaching is often criticized
as well, that's really useful
for the people who aren't
learning anything, but
the top 5%, it will
just slow them down.
So we can't possibly do it.
So the wars about interactive
teaching turn on
a lot of that question.
And that is a very
similar force.
Because people are saying well,
it's those people who
are just like me, because
they're the ones who are going
to become future faculty.
And those ones aren't going to
be benefited by the system.
Now I think, empirically,
that's not true.
I think they are actually
benefited, as well.
And Benezet found that too.
It wasn't that some
people did worse.
They were all doing better.
But it's the intensity of the
response that you get to
things sometimes in that vein
shows that its an underlying
social force and not just purely
a cognitive reason.
Is that what you were
thinking about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so 10:08, so
10:18, we'll start again with
more questions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: So I know there are
several more questions,
because I already have
two in the queue.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: My question is--
PROFESSOR: And then
[? Lortis. ?]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What do you do when
you're confronted with a
question you don't know
the answer to.
PROFESSOR: What do you--
I don't know?
No, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
The question was, what do you do
when you're confronted with
a question that you don't
know the answer to?
And my answer was
I have no idea.
No, there's good answers to that
question, and hopefully,
I'll give you one of them.
So I would say the number one
thing is not to bullshit.
That can only end--
at best, it won't
end in disaster.
But it can end in disaster.
The first thing--
so if you don't know the answer
to it, but you have to
think of what's going to
get triggered in you?
So if it's something, for
example, really related to the
material, you're more likely to
get triggered and think--
[GASPS]
Excuse me.
Oh, I should have known the
answer that, I must be a lousy
teacher, how will they ever
respect me again?
So if you remember the
discussion we had last time in
political barriers about the
three levels at which
conversations are carried on,
so this was from difficult
conversations, there's the
factual level, the emotional
level, and the meaning level.
So the fact level is that
someone just asked you a
question, and you don't know
the answer right away.
The emotional reaction, and the
emotional transmission, is
oh my God, I feel worried
and nervous.
And then the meaning level
is oh, what does
that mean for me?
Oh, it means that I'm
a bad teacher.
They found me out.
I'm really not supposed
to be here.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So that same thing
happens with students when you
ask them a question, and
they don't know.
So you want to create structures
where that bad
meaning, isn't triggered.
So you want to just pause,
first of all.
The reason is, if you don't
pause, then you're more likely
to act out, based
on the emotion.
So I've seen this happen several
times when I was a
graduate student.
So this is sometimes when the
person didn't know, but in
general, when they were somehow
challenged by a
question, so either way, whether
it's because you don't
know the answer, or because the
student's tone has some
kind of cheekiness to it, and
you feel a bit of insolence,
and then you think, I'm the
teacher God dammit, how dare
you talk to me like that?
So that emotional reaction, or
that challenge, that worry,
that anxiety about your
authority will produce a bad
response, in general.
So if you just, right away,
respond, you are likely to do
bad things.
And this is a thing I've seen
happen a few times, is where
you put the student down, you
compete with the student, you
say things like, well, how
could you not know that?
And you dismiss the question.
So if you pause for just one
or two seconds, even an
instant after you practice it,
just the pausing to realize
oh, wait a minute, I just had an
emotional reaction happen,
I felt in my body, I got a bit
sweaty, my palms sweated,
whatever it may be that your
particular reaction is.
I feel it often in my face--
my face gets warm.
If you remember, way back
when we were doing--
was it the wood blocks
or the cones?
No, it was the cones.
I was dropping the cones.
And there was a question when it
was time for questions and
discussion.
One person said, oh, the answer
is block, and I've seen
you do it before, and I just
remember just feeling flushed.
I was like, this is not the time
to answer that question.
So it's the same thing.
So that's lesson number
one is to pause.
And then you can think
and regroup and have
a reflective response.
The reflective response may
be, oh, that's a really
interesting question, I'd never
thought about that, but
I'm going to think about that
tonight, and I'll tell
you the next time.
That's perfectly fine.
Another one is you
can try to figure
out the answer together.
You say, well I'm not sure, but
let's see if we can figure
out the answer in the
next minute or two.
If not, I'll work on it in the
evening or work on it tomorrow
and tell you.
And then you can try it
together, and students have
the advantage of seeing
how you would
reason about a question.
And it helps if you do
that intentionally.
Because there's a general rule
of thumb which is that one's
facility with equations declines
with distance to the
blackboard.
So the closer to the blackboard,
the lower the
facility of the equation.
So if you just leap to the
blackboard and start writing,
you're likely to feel too
nervous and actually just mess
it up just because of that.
So if you say, well, let's
actually think about doing
this together, think about what
you might do, and think
about some approaches, then go
to the blackboard and maybe
start working.
And when you have your out, it
doesn't work in two minutes,
you say look, it's
a good question.
I clearly need to think
about this some
more, and I'll do that.
And I'll come back to you.
Does that help answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, because we were
just talking about just having
these discussion with
our students.
And I feel like perhaps there
would be somebody who would
point out a different way
of doing something.
And then you aren't really
prepared to talk
about that with them.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you're going to do
interactive teaching, you're
going to have lots
of discussion.
So people think, oh, interactive
teaching means you
just let the students do
everything, you kick back.
No, it's actually much harder.
Because you've changed it back
from basically playing a
prerecorded tape, which is what
a lot of lecturing is--
you just get out and read the
book, that's what a lot of my
lecturers did--
to now it's a stage
performance--
a stage performance in the old
days of Elizabethan theater
where the audience interacted
with the stage.
So that's much harder.
You have to, quote, "Know your
lines." Not that you're going
to say the same lines no matter
what-- you have to
really feel the lines.
You have to really understand
the feel.
So it is harder.
And you're going to be producing
lots of discussions.
And at a place like MIT, the
students are very curious.
And they're going to think,
oh, well, what about this?
Well, that's fine.
So you want to use Aikido.
So if someone suggests something
you haven't thought
of, don't dismiss it.
You say, oh, I hadn't thought of
that, that's a really good
suggestion, which then, usually,
maybe, I'll use that
next year when I teach the
course, thank you.
So if you just think about the
students as your allies, then
your reaction that you'll
intrinsically produce will be
much less confrontational
and much less worried.
So I'll give you one example
of where I was very, very
nervous and what I did.
So I was lecturing
thermodynamics, and there was
200 students.
And I was doing the Carnot
cycle, so this
was the last lecture.
So we were doing the Carnot
cycle, and I drew
it up on the board.
And I'd encouraged questions
throughout the whole lecture,
throughout the whole
lecture course.
So, of course, someone raised
their hand and said, oh,
excuse me, I think that
this box is not right.
They didn't know what was wrong,
but they said, oh, that
box isn't right.
So I looked at it, and
I thought, oh my
God, they're right.
So I'd now just drawn rubbish
on the board for 200 people,
and I had a bunch of my
colleagues that day who
happened to decide that
was the day to
come visit my lecture.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So I think that was
probably why I was a bit
nervous to begin with.
And that probably contributed
to me writing
down the wrong diagram.
So I realized I needed some time
to actually think, so I
just said, you know,
you're right.
Let me just think.
And I just turned my back, for
a whole minute, and I sorted
out what was wrong.
And then everything was
fine after that.
But I still remember that.
I still remember the feeling in
my body, just that sinking
feeling of oh my God, disaster
has happened.
I've just been exposed.
And really, I should've
been one of the
students in the class.
So pausing is immensely
valuable.
[? Lordis? ?]
AUDIENCE: Follow up to the
question that was said before,
how do you effectively argue
against [INAUDIBLE]
to the top students?
PROFESSOR: Right, so often
when you want to do so
something more interactive in
your teaching, the counter
arguments are well, you're
going to harm the top 5%.
Well, one counter argument--
so first of all, it doesn't
often help to counter argue
cognitive reasons if there's
an emotional underpinning.
So generally, I try to step
aside from those arguments,
unless the people have a
sense of humor, I find.
If the people have a sense of
humor, then you can present
things in a humorous way that
challenge their view, and they
can take it on board.
But if they don't have a sense
of humor, or you don't have a
good way of presenting it that
way, I find it's just wiser to
step aside and see if you can
find some way around it.
Maybe try half of what you
wanted to do, or say, well,
yeah, I worry about
that too, a bit.
So let's leave the main
course alone that way.
Let's try an experiment
and see how it goes.
Maybe we can agree on some
questions that all the
students should be able to do to
try to make it cooperative.
So that's one thing.
But if you do want to go
directly into cognitive
discussions and reasons, one
is, and this has scope for
making humor out of,
[? I've ?] said,
what's a top student?
The top students, the top,
quote, "5%" are the top 5% by
the current system of testing
and homeworks.
So they're are often
the top 5% in
regurgitating canned formulas.
Or by the time they get higher
and higher and more selections
happened, they're good at
pattern matching and solving
problems they don't
even understand.
I mean certainly, the final exam
in Cambridge that people
took in their final year-- if
I just sat down, I would not
have passed it in the
physics department.
And so there were students who
did really, really well on it.
But I'm sure I understood
more physics than them.
And it's because if you train
for those kind of questions,
even if you don't really
understand what you're doing,
you can actually answer them.
So now the top 5% at
that, well is that
so valuable to preserve?
Maybe actually we should change
the rules of the game.
So now, if you just say it as
directly as I've said it, then
you'll trigger the meaning of--
well, because a lot of
times, those 5% became the
people you're talking to.
So you have to maybe do it
slightly differently, and say,
look, what is the thing you're
most concerned about, about
the students not knowing,
whether they're
the top 5% or not?
And a lot of times,
they'll just give
you a big, long list.
On their own, before you even
say it, they'll say, oh, they
can never use anything
outside of the class.
So people will just outright
concede that, not even concede
it, they'll say, yeah,
it's so terrible.
And people will talk about this
all the time, and say,
look, we all agree that.
Well, let's see, is there a way
that we can make people
really good at that?
Because even the top 5%, I
find, are not like that.
So now you've opened a door.
And you can have a shared
discussion based on
something like that.
So that's how you can reach the
80% who are not sure but
are willing to listen.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering what
you think of the surveys that
they have at MIT by which the
students evaluate the
professors and teachers, and
also, how to interpret the
results of those?
PROFESSOR: Oh good,
I'm glad you said
that for several reasons.
So one of the other reasons is
that this course has one too.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So I'll put
it on the course
website just after class.
So 595 is one of the
course numbers.
But it's also 6.92 or something,
so all course six
classes have an online
evaluation system.
So for everybody, we're
doing it that way.
So everybody who is registered
for the class is listed as a
possible survey filler-outer.
So I encourage everyone--
I'll put the link
on the website.
Just click on the link, and if
you have your MIT certificates
installed, it'll just take
you to the online survey.
So I think the surveys
are very useful.
Now the numbers are
a ballpark--
well, were things
working or not?
But I think the most useful
part of the surveys is the
comments people make.
So again, I encourage you to
make comments in the comment
boxes, wherever they are.
For example, there's one that
says, what would you suggest
for people next year?
So part of that I'm going to
learn by reading these.
So I'll crib good ideas from how
you would do this course
from your homeworks.
But the survey will actually
help with that.
So I think the surveys
are really
useful, if used properly.
I don't think they're very
useful for saying, you get
tenure, you don't get tenure.
Because people just use
the numbers for that.
I don't think the numbers
are super reliable.
I mean seven is probably
significantly better than four
or five, but there are a lot of
ways to get six and a half,
and six or five.
How did that happen?
Well, you want to really look
into the course and see that.
And the course survey
doesn't really
address that super well.
But the comments give you space,
if you really listen
closely, to understand it.
So I think they're
quite useful.
But what I'd really
like to see--
because those are surveys right
after the class, and my
goal, what I've been trying to
stress this whole time, is how
can you construct teaching for
a long lasting learning,
questioning and reflecting,
ideally for a
long lasting learning?
Well, if it really lasts long,
people should remember
something a year later.
So I think actually the policy
should be changed to do
feedback sheets at the end of
each lecture, so you get the
quick feedback you need
as the lecturer.
And then by the end of this
course, you have a lot of
feedback, and you can really
improve things next time.
And then do the survey a year
after the course is finished.
And if people don't remember
anything from the course right
away, that's a pretty important
piece of feedback.
So I fear though that the
results from that kind of
survey would be quite
distressing.
Because you'd ask things like,
well, which of the ideas from
the course do you use?
And people have done surveys
like that in physics majors.
So they're surveys of physics
majors in the job, whether
their in research or in
industry or finance--
well, before that ended--
what do you use from your
physics degree?
And very rarely do you find
people saying, if you just
average across all the jobs,
Maxwell's equations.
It's just not on the list--
is very low on the list.
It's things like general problem
solving, quantitative
skills, working in groups.
Now it's not necessarily true
that therefore we should just
dump all our classes and teach
people how to work in groups.
That's not what I'm saying.
But it's useful to know what
people are doing with the
things you teach them,
so that you can
take that into account.
So that would be my ideal--
surveys one year, five years,
10 years, later.
And there are a few of those
at MIT, alumni surveys.
[? Meki, ?]
I know, has done
a few of them.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So let's say you're
a new teacher, and you're
giving a course.
And you design it, and you
really think about how you
want to do it, and the labs and
the homeworks, et cetera.
And you refine that over
a number of years.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, two
or three years.
AUDIENCE: So five or six years,
you've got it down
pretty well.
Does it become boring?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Yeah, so the question is you
make a new course, two or
three years you've refined it,
after five years, does it
become boring?
My guess is probably yeah,
unless you keep changing it.
So I've taught Art of
Approximation for
almost nine years now.
And every three years or four
years, I completely figure out
a new way of doing it.
And now it's finally converging,
I would say.
I've finally realized,
oh the main thing--
because I didn't know this when
I first started, because
I was a new teacher--
so to organize it around large
ideas, main themes,
transferable technique.
So I've finally converged
to that.
And now I'm changing
the examples.
And so I would say
the [INAUDIBLE]
is probably converging.
But I could probably keep doing
that for another three
or four years.
But if you just do it, refine it
for two or three years, and
then just keep doing it, I would
say yeah, after another
couple years, it's not
necessarily that it will get
boring, because when you teach
this way, the teaching always
stays interesting, but it's that
you find yourself maybe
just thinking about
other courses.
And I already have a sign that
that's happening, because I'm
now thinking, I'd like to make
a Physics of Music class.
And they may be related
to the other class.
Because we just did the wood
blocks and the xylophone in my
approximation class.
I'm thinking, oh, a whole class
of the physics of music
would be really a lot
of fun to make--
organize it around
demonstrations, and then you
could bring in the physics,
as needed, for the
demonstrations, and you choose
all the demonstrations so that
all the main physical ideas
in acoustics, and
electromagnetism, and
mechanics, and
sound are all combined.
Oh that'll be a really
nice design problem.
So maybe I'm converging with the
Art of Approximation one
after nine years.
So it depends how often you
keep changing things.
But yeah, and that's OK, because
you'll find that
that's the natural life cycle.
So for example, if you're a
faculty member say in almost
any university in the country,
after six years, you get a
sabbatical.
So in the sabbatical, you'd
be very well advised--
I mean, you could teach if you
wanted-- but you're very well
advised to not show up on any
committees, not teach, and
generally, you're pretty
much required not to
and then just leave.
Because otherwise, you'll be
dealing with all the normal,
run of the mill things.
You wouldn't be able to have a
block of time to really think.
So if you've developed this
course, and it's your course,
after five or six years, it's
automatically going to have to
be given to somebody else.
And that's fine.
Because that's around the time
that you'll be thinking about
other stuff.
And the sabbatical is a time to
reorient yourself towards
other stuff.
So looking ahead towards that,
what you want to do is write
up what you do.
So the first year, it's pretty
hard, you're just barely
scrambling, you're trying
to breathe.
It's like having four children,
or us having
quadruplets.
Well, maybe, I don't know, I
haven't had that happen to me.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: But the first year
you do a brand new course,
especially a three days a week
one, it's pretty hard.
So I can tell you, this is two
hours a week, but it's the
first time I've taught
this course.
So it's a lot of work.
And that will be true.
So the first year, yeah, you
just want to survive.
The second year, you start to
figure out what to do, what to
write, and just start writing
stuff up bit by bit--
lecture notes, problem sets that
are type set, things that
other people can use
pretty easily.
So then when the course is
handed off to somebody else,
they can continue that and
refine it, based on what
you've done.
And everything you did
doesn't just vanish.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned in
classes you really like to
[? do a lot of ?]
teaching and [? carve ?] the
main ideas and then put some
of the mechanistic--
PROFESSOR: The grunge.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So do you have anything
illuminating to say about how
to choose those textbook
[? readings, ?] other than
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
the question is--
so I like to use lecture time
for the larger ideas, for the
concepts, for the chunks.
So for example, in the teaching
equation one, and
leave the derivations and
detailed manipulations, the
mechanics of stuff, the grunge
let's say, for the textbook.
Do I have any suggestions for
how to choose a good textbook?
Well, it is important to
choose a good textbook.
But it becomes less important
if the classroom is focusing
on concepts in chunks.
Because that's the
differentiator, generally,
between the good and the bad
textbooks, is that the good
textbooks do more of that.
So if you're focusing on that
in the classroom, then you
have more freedom--
not freedom to use bad
textbooks, but the bad
textbooks don't do
you as much harm.
Because the students
don't need so
much out of the textbook.
They need to basically have a
place where the derivations
are correct.
And that's an important part,
and it has the derivations you
need, sure.
So right away, you
can relax about
choosing textbooks, slightly.
But how do you find good ones?
Actually now, I look at the
reviews online and see what
students say about them.
So I do a web search for books,
and I see what books
people are using, what people
are commenting on, look at the
online bookstores, the various
reviews of the books.
That helps a lot.
And then, nowadays, often people
put the first chapter
and the Table of Contents
online--
the publishers do.
And ideally, they would put
the whole book online.
Some are doing that too.
So have a look at that.
From the Table of Contents,
you can really tell a lot
about a textbook.
You can say, is this
organized right?
Does this have the
right philosophy
that I'm looking for?
So look, right away, at the
preface, where the author
talks about why this book.
And if they have no good reason
for why this book, it's
probably not the book for you.
Sometimes you don't have a
choice about the book.
People just say, well, this is
the book that we always use.
Or it's the first time you've
taught the course.
For example, you're hired say
in March, you start your job
in July, and in August, they
come to you and say, oh yeah,
by the way, Professor Blah is
on sabbatical teaching X,
you're up, the course book
is already there.
So you can't do much
about that.
So sometimes you don't have
freedom, but then when you do,
you want to do it.
So look at the preface and
the online reviews.
They're quite helpful.
But don't worry as much if your
classroom is interactive.
That mitigates a lot of
textbook problems.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you [? focused ?]
on the fact that in Europe, in
your undegrad, you take more
specific classes towards
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: And I wonder actually
if there is some
[? standard ?] or analysis of
what is more effective.
Because in general, I goes that
if you have more variety,
than you have a higher
tendency to do more
disciplinary work.
[INAUDIBLE] that would
be the advantage.
But the advantage of having
taken only chemistry, math,
and physics during your
undergrad is that then you
know a lot about that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And that also
goes a little bit--
I don't know, I keep hearing,
although I have never seen
proof that math skills in the
US are not as good as the
people who come from outside.
And also, [? because ?] we were
talking about doing a
class on music and--
PROFESSOR: Physics
and music, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then I wonder if
I'll ever get an undergrad
that took that class instead of
taking a physics hardcore
math class.
And I'd be like, oh, I wish you
had taken this class that
would give you the tools to
work, rather than some class
that you would enjoy, but that
I'd rather have you taking,
later on, at the end of
your grad school.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let
me unpack those.
So there were several
questions in there.
So first, are there any studies
on the difference
between the results produced
by the European's, say,
educational system versus the
American, or the European
where people just do their one
subject to first order, where
the American one where you
take courses across many
different subjects?
I'm not sure about that.
But also, the notion of
effectiveness is not clear, so
what's the goal?
So that the American one, I
think the historical reasons
why it's different is that
education in America, early
on, back in colonial times, and
just post-colonial or the
early 1800s, was seen as
a democratic thing.
The idea was that this is
a democracy, and all the
citizens are expected to
participate in that.
And so they had a narrow
definition of citizens--
just white males--
but within that definition, the
idea was that everybody
had to participate or was
going to participate.
So to that end, they needed
a broad education.
They couldn't just specialize
in one thing.
Because they would
be too narrow to
actually help govern society.
Because society is
multi-farious and
multi-disciplinary,
intrinsically.
Whereas in Europe, that idea of
democracy came hundreds of
years later, if at all, maybe at
the end of World War I. So
the European educational system
was much more oriented
towards producing people who
would fit into a particular
slot in society.
So now if you want to measure
how effective each was at its
historical goals, I think
that's a fair question.
To measure how effective each is
at producing people who are
trained for a particular
slot in society--
I don't think that's a
very useful analysis.
Because the historical
origins of the
two systems are different.
It's much more fruitful,
I would say, to
think about the goals.
Which goals do we agree with?
Can we get the benefits of the
American goal with some of the
benefits of the specialization
in Europe?
And I think at places like
MIT, you do do that.
The students who come
out of MIT--
they have a broader education
than the students who come out
of European universities, and
they actually know a lot.
Now I would like it
to be much more
conceptual and long lasting.
But that's true of the
European ones too.
So I would take the question
back from just studying the
end result to think
carefully, as a
society, about their purposes.
Now about the Physics of Music,
I would say, actually,
I could imagine teaching an
intro physics course that's
Physics of Music, where students
would learn all the
fundamental ideas of say first
semester physics, but through
the physics of music.
And so they wouldn't be deprived
of the essential
knowledge of physics.
They would actually
be contextualized.
So it might have longer
lasting value.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, other-- yes?
AUDIENCE: So you talk about
emotional barriers, and I
think one of the big ones that
I've seen, especially in
students at MIT, through TA'ing
or just through hearing
people talk is I don't
belong here.
I must have gotten
here by accident.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I think so many
people say that to themselves,
at one time or another, or
multiple times while they're
here, that it can't possibly
be true, because
everybody is saying it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Because if they have
that barrier up, I don't think
there's much to do
to combat that.
So how do you get through
that kind of barrier?
Because no matter how clear your
teaching is, if they're
worried that they're not
going to get it,
because they don't belong--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if they're
in the math phobic
mode or phobic mode.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So this is a really
interesting question.
So the comment was that a lot
of people at MIT, a lot of
students, one of the emotional
barriers they
have is they feel--
I would call that a
meaning barrier.
Let me rephrase it in the three
levels of conversation.
So their emotion
is that they're
very tense and anxious.
And the meaning is that when
something doesn't go right for
them, they get something wrong
on a problem set or in class,
they think that that's exposing
how they really don't
belong here.
And that creates a
lot of anxiety
and tension and misery.
So at Caltech, there was a
saying that, oh yeah, Caltech
is a terrible place for the
bottom half of the 99th
percentile, which captures
that pretty well.
All these people, all the
undergrads who went to Caltech--
they were probably
valedictorians in their high
school and two sigmas above in
doing science fair projects
than everybody else
around them.
And now they come to Caltech,
and they feel terrible.
What are we doing that
produces that?
It's crazy.
So how can your teaching-- can
you take account of that?
So that, I would say, also
relates partly to the
misconceptions.
They have this misconception
or this conception about
themselves.
So what can you do?
Well phobias are
very difficult.
You have to work around them.
So one thing is, you don't
want to trigger them.
So every time you trigger them,
you reinforce them.
So any neurobiology
people in here?
I forget.
[? PCS? ?]
Well the fundamental rule
of neurobiology of brain
neurons-- so this is-- of
course, I teach Art of
Approximation, so forgive me
for approximating the whole
brain with one sentence--
is neurons that fire together
wire together.
So wiring together, that means
they activate, they increase
their coupling.
And so for example, you create
a classroom environment or
something happened in the
classroom that they get
something wrong.
And now that is still wired,
somewhat, to the bad feeling
and their thoughts of oh my
God, I don't belong here.
So now you've reinforced
that, they're going to
wire together more.
It reinforces that pathway.
So what you have to do is find
a way to actually prevent
those guys from wiring
together.
One thing is create an
environment where whenever
people get things wrong,
it's actually great.
So oh, that wasn't right, great,
now think how much
you're going to learn.
Or when you get things wrong,
you want to model that too.
You say, oh you're right,
oh thanks, I've learned
something from that.
So try not to be defensive.
Because if you're defensive,
then that triggers
that wiring in them.
And that firing together builds
up the wiring together.
So creating a classroom
environment where feeling bad
and competing against other
people isn't the goal is one
way to minimize it.
So minimizing the importance
of defined distinctions on
homework-- did I get a 95?
Or oh, that person's getting
a 95, I only got a 90.
So that's one reason
MIT was pass/fail.
For a whole year, originally,
was pass/fail.
And that was to mitigate the
pressure that students were
coming in, feeling like, oh my
God, now I don't belong here.
[? It was ?]
look, we don't care about your
grades in the first year.
You're really here to adjust to
university, to a different
way of learning, and now, it
was actually done in a way
that somehow the competition
was partly the students
reinforcing the culture, the
upperclassmen, as well.
If you could actually try to
mitigate that, you'd go a long
way towards mitigating
the wiring together.
But you can do it in your
classroom too by deemphasizing
the things that trigger that.
And so when you call
on people--
so for example, for that reason
at MIT, I almost never
what's called cold calling.
If you've ever seen that old
movie The Paper Chase--
so The Paper Chase is about the
what we could call today
the terroristic Socratic
method.
So the law schools all use the
Socratic method, where they
read a case, and you ask
them about things--
things about it.
Mr. Jones, what do you think,
what were the findings of law?
Mr. Smith or Mrs. d'Arbeloff,
what do you think about that,
do you agree with that, or
is that pure rubbish?
So people were just put on the
spot repeatedly, and they just
produced terror in the students,
and that was
considered part of the hazing
ritual, basically.
So at MIT, I just don't
do that at all.
Because I think it just
triggers that.
And I'd rather just create a
structure whereby students
feel ready to participate,
by, for example, in the
interactive teaching, giving
them time to think to each
other and then say something.
So you can do stuff, and
it's hard, and it's
an important problem.
Yeah?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's worthwile to
actually confront it head on,
is just say, a lot of you may
be feeling this way, and
please know that it's normal,
and in fact, I felt this way
most of my life.
Because I had a professor in my
undergrad who actually came
in and said to a group of us--
like, it was in a meeting.
And she said, how many of you
have felt like, basically,
you're an imposter and it's
just a matter of time
[INAUDIBLE] discovers you?
[INAUDIBLE]
all of us raised our hands.
And she said, I wanted you to
know that it wasn't until I
won my fourth major award in
the field that I stopped
feeling that way.
So It's normal.
And that's run in my
head for years.
So even someone who was amazing
as she was, and she
was an amazing individual, has
felt that way, and to know
that you're not the only
one [INAUDIBLE].
So do you think it's actually
worth saying?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's
a really good point.
So the point was that it's
worthwhile making it explicit
for the students and really
naming the feeling that
they're going through.
Like look, you may be feeling
really terrible and feeling
like you're an imposter.
Well, let it be known that I
felt the same way too for a
long time, and describe it to
them, and talk to them about
why they may be feeling that.
Say look, there's a culture of
competition in the society and
the university, and
it's actually
harmful for your learning.
And share with them some
readings about that.
Help them see that yeah, this is
something they're going to
have to struggle with.
But there's help to do that, and
they're not alone in that.
So yeah, definitely be explicit
about things like that.
I think more question, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just in a follow-up,
do you think that
contextualizing the course
is a way to fight that?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Do I think conceptualizing the
course is a way to fight that?
I think it is.
Because when the course is not
contextualized, it generally
tends to be really abstractly
focused.
And the interest and the
orientation towards doing
things first abstractly
is very rare.
I don't have it, and
I've gone really
far in math and physics.
My office mate had it
in graduate school.
He was the only person I've ever
met who would rather have
a proof than a picture.
And now he's a professor
at Caltech, and
he's also doing well.
But it's pretty rare.
So by contextualizing the
course, for almost everybody,
actually I would say even for
my friend and office mate,
you're actually connecting to
a much larger part of their
mind and their experience.
So you're actually making people
much more intelligent
and much more equal
in that way.
So that's one reason I would
actually like to teach the
Physics in Music class.
AUDIENCE: It made me think
[INAUDIBLE] they teach drugs
in the brain [INAUDIBLE]
biology.
So if you're a physicist and
you're like, I can't do
biology, you can take drugs
in the brain [INAUDIBLE].
And they teach you biology
by teaching [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
Yeah, so it somehow
gets around the
phobia you might have.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: They do that
at [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
So I was there 10 years ago,
and that wasn't true then.
So the comment was that at
Caltech now the required
classes all have a contextual
version, as well.
And I think that's
a great idea.
It's also, from your point of
view, it's really fun as a
future teacher, because you
get to think of all the
interesting contexts in which
your field is useful.
It connects you back to the
reason you did the field,
originally.
And that's good to remember.
Because you'll be going along,
and you'll be absorbed in your
research, trying to get tenure,
whatever it may be,
and there will be all these
layers that are created on
top, and you'll forget
why you came into the
field to begin with.
And if you can capture that
feeling, actually if you can
connect to that feeling in you,
then you'll actually be
able to transmit that feeling
to your students.
And they'll have it, as well,
and you'll actually be doing
good for the field,
good for you, and
good for your students.
So with that, I'll
wish you lots of
success in your teaching.
I hope that the principles and
examples that we've done
throughout the term you find
useful, at least in one way.
And I look forward to hearing
from you later how you use or
not use or any suggestions
that you may have.
So good luck.
[APPLAUSE]